And now for the next few videos I'm going to show you an actually coded up
example of PCA as applied to facial recognition.
This is taken and adapted from an example on the sklearn documentation, so
I'll include a link to the original code so you can go in and take a look at it,
but I want to walk you through some of the most important parts.
So the first thing that the code does is,
import a set of pictures of famous world leaders from about 10 to 15 years ago.
The next thing that it does is it splits it into a training and testing set.
Very good, but then this block right here is where the PCA actually happens.
You'll see in this example, and sometimes in the literature that PCA is
also called eigenfaces when it's applied to facial recognition.
So in this line here we actually see the PCA being created,
it's called RandomizedPCA in sklearn.
And then it's also being fit to the training data.
Then what this line does here is it asks for the eigenfaces.
The eigenfaces are basically the principle components of the face data.
So it takes the pca.components, and then it reshapes them.
because right now they're just strings of numbers, and
it wants to turn those back into squares so that they look like pictures.
You can also see that the number of principal components that are being used in
this example is 150.
And if you look at the example code on the sklearn documentation page,
you'll see that the original dimensionality of these pictures is over 1,800.
So we've gone from 1,800 features down to 150,
a compression factor of more than 10.
Then the last thing that I do with PCA is I transform my data.
When I perform the fit command I'm
just figuring out what the principle components are.
It's these transform commands where I actually take my data and
transform them into the principle components representation.
And the rest of this code is creating an SVM.
Remember the SVC is what its called in sklearn,
a support vector classifier.
They do a little bit of fancy footwork here to figure out exactly what
parameters of the support vector machine they want to use.
And then using the principle components as the features,
they try to identify in the test set who appears in a given picture.
Now I'll show you what this looks like when I run this code.
First thing that it does is it prints out a doc string,
just tells me what's going on.
And then some information about the data set.
So I have 1,288 samples,
with 1,850 features available to me in the input feature space.
Seven different people are appearing and
then we use 150 eigenfaces from the 966 faces in our training set.
The next thing that appears is a list of the people in our data set, and
how often we get them correct.
Precision, recall, f1-score and support are things that are sort of
related to the accuracy, their evaluation matrix.
We'll talk a lot about those in a coming lesson.
You can see that in general though, it's getting things correct.
Roughly 60% to almost 90% of the time.
So even though we've reduced our dimensionality by a factor of ten,
we're still having really good performance.
Another thing that's really cool that I love about this example is they
actually show you the eigenfaces.
So this is the first principle component of our data, and
this is the second principle component, the third one.
So this image here represents the maximal variation that it
sees across all the data.
It's a little bit hard to understand exactly what that means in this example.
It would be better if it said something like,
how far apart the eyes are, or whether the person wears glasses or not.
Instead, what we get are these kind of ghost images.
But then using these composite images together as features in an SVM,
it can be very powerful in predicting who's face we see.
And then last but
not least, there's a little printout that gives you 12 representative faces and
the algorithms best guess about who it is, and the actual answer.
So you can see it doesn't always get them correct.
This one right here I think this is Tony Blair, but it's actually George W Bush,
but on most of them it's getting it correct, pretty cool.